und einfach hier noch eine limitierte
hose keine ahnung warum die so fucking
teuer ist ich finde es eigentlich ganz
okay für 800 euro auf keinen fall wenn
ich die jetzt werfen sollte dann haben
wir wirklich ein kleines problem und
[Musik]
nein
hey leute was geht ab jetzt willkommen
bei einem neuen video heute mal wieder
bei diesem heißen wetter draußen ist
aber umso besser denn heute wird es
wieder ein bisschen gefährlich wir
werfen heute darf eine zweite runde ich
weiß nicht ob ich es gesehen habt es gab
ja von mir dieses video ich werde für
einen dartpfeil und dort wo er landet
fahre ich essen also eine map hatten wir
da das war ja gar nicht mal so schlecht
wenn man sich das jetzt so anschaut ist
natürlich schwierig zu sagen starbucks
oder danken daun haben wir das noch
nicht gesehen habt schaut euch einfach
nach diesem video als auch extrem cool
geworden und durch dieses video bin ich
auf eine zweite idee gekommen stand auch
in den kommentaren und zwar entsteht
dieses video in kooperation mit st
da kann ich ja immer fleißig klamotten
einkaufen und ich hab heute eine kleine
challenge überlegt es gibt insgesamt
glaube ich sechs kategorien wir haben
zum beispiel caps wir haben shirts wir
haben pullover wir haben hosen wir haben
unterwäsche wir haben keine ahnung
irgendwas noch und wie schon gesagt ich
kann mir jeden monat klamotten aussuchen
für den bestimmten preis und ich habe
mir für dieses video eine kleine
challenge überlegt und zwar habe ich mir
viele sachen rausgesucht die mir
gefallen allerdings sind darunter immer
sachen die besonders günstig sind und
sachen die besonders teuer sind ich kann
es euch hier zeigen wir haben wir zum
beispiel schon diese map gemacht haben
wir fünf verschiedene caps diese kostet
zb 52 euro diese kostet nur 7 euro die
es nicht von gucci sondern von eugene
und ich war beim friseur das ganze geht
allerdings noch viel kraft hat zum
beispiel haben wir auch eine hose für
799 euro werde ich auf jeden fall gleich
sehen ich will gar nicht eingeladen
haben wir die da teile und die
entscheiden jetzt von dieser position
aus ich habe hier so ein brett hingelegt
weil ich meine dass überhaupt bretländer
was ich alles kaufen wir fangen mit den
caps abend dort wo der fall landet
welche pindl am nächsten dran ist das
wird gekauft und ja das lustige daran
ist halt wenn ich besonders viele sachen
treffe die teuer sind kann ich mir nicht
so viel aus suchen mein handy ist hier
auch vielleicht sie habe aufnehmen also
wir starten mit dem ersten fall die
distanz ist auf jeden fall ziemlich groß
deswegen hat man eigentlich kaum
einfluss darauf ich muss das ding erst
mal treffen und vielleicht geht der fall
auch oben durch diese blätter durch 321
nächster
da bin ich behindert und jetzt war
[Musik]
ich hasse ist
so ich habe es wieder aufgestellt man
sich hier ganz klar hier ist es gelandet
in dieser cap die fand ich eigentlich
auch am besten die kostet sieben euro
kerpen war ich würde sagen wir machen
weiter mit einem scherz da haben wir
ganz viele deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
das ist ja so mahlich braucht viele neue
t-shirts wir werfen drei feinde aber ich
muss erstmal alle t-shirts an bringen
also leute auch hier haben wir halt mich
auf dem david auch nicht auf die wade
getreten
wir haben insgesamt acht shirts darunter
sind welche für 32 euro für zehn euro
für 15 euro für 60 euro aber auch für
350 euro das heißt wenn ich dieses shirt
treffe habe ich ein kleines problem dann
ist schon ziemlich großer teil des
budgets aufgebraucht also mit sco wir
haben drei meide ich bin gespannt
[Musik]
okay ich bin eigentlich zufrieden
dieser fall ist ganz klar am nächsten an
dieser nadel das heißt dieses shirt für
65 euro
meyer ich als zweites kommt dieses shirt
für 15 euro dazu und ich würde sagen da
dieser fall ansonsten das ist obwohl
hier der ist klar hier dran das heißt ja
dass pepsi shirt wir haben das helly
hansen shirt und wir haben das polar
skate shirt ich bin natürlich auch hier
mal den gesamtbetrag ein und wir machen
weiter mit der nächsten kategorie und
das sind pullover bei dem wetter ähnlich
aber für den winter hat so wir haben wir
fünf verschiedene police zum beispiel
einmal diesen hier für 19 euro dann aber
auch diesen hier für 130 euro
dieser hier kostet tun hat habe ich
leider abgeschnitten das ding ist schon
fast eine jacke 180 euro und 20 euro
hier werden von jetzt insgesamt zwei
teile geworfen und ich würde sagen jetzt
auch ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen
mich hier wieder spitze in der sonne
hätte ich besser heute abend drehen aber
es soll ja heute noch online
ich bin eigentlich für den orangen pulli
den final
das ist der für 19 euro und jetzt
[Musik]
scheiße
leute wir haben einmal ganz klar den für
19 euro und wir haben moment sieht man
hier wenn ich das jetzt so weiter drehen
würde wird um längen nicht drankommen
das heißt einmal den für 19 euro und den
für 130 euro kommen wir zur nächsten
kategorie und das sind schuhe oder hosen
sondern habe ich auch noch ich tue die
markierung mal ein bisschen nach vorne
weil ich werde es einfach die ganze zeit
daneben also haben jetzt sechs paar
schuhe einmal hier zum beispiel für 215
euro wenig für 90 euro dann aber auch
welche für den 24 oder 40 euro
der ist für meine mutter wenn ich dann
werfen sollte würde ich sagen und hier
werden jetzt auch wieder zwei pfeile
geworfen
[Musik]
jetzt muss ich sagen den schuh für mich
ist gar nicht dabei zwei pfeile einmal
hier 24 eur 40 euro beide für meine
mutter die ihr wichtig für mich gewesen
aber ja also ist dass wir wollen hier
nichts fällt deswegen so günstig davon
gekommen wir kommen als nächstes zu den
hosen wir haben insgesamt fünf stück und
zwar habe ich mir hier passend zum
sommer 504 jeansshorts rausgesucht für
ungefähr jeweils jahr zwischen 20 und 40
euro und einfach hier noch eine
limitierte hose keine ahnung warum die
so fucking teuer ist ich finde es
eigentlich ganz okay zu 800 euro auf
keinen fall wenn ich dir jetzt werden
sollte dann haben wir wirklich ein
kleines problem auch an dieser stelle
komme ich würd sagen drei fälle
dann ist die wahrscheinlichkeit schon
ziemlich hoch dass sich diese scheiß
hose treffe okay die erste jeans die
zweite trinkt nein ja einmal diese
beiden jeanshosen und der pfeil ist mit
abstand am nächsten dran als wäre ich
mich so über die eigenen füße laufen ich
habe genau hierhin gezielt und er geht
dahin hat jemand von euch schon mal eine
adidas hose für 800 euro getragen die
leute damit ihr mir das auch wirklich
glaubt dass wir zum beispiel eine hose
800 euro kostet ich weiß nicht warum ich
wollte das jetzt mal kurz in der sache
auf den grund gehen kann ja von adidas
diese jogginghose an sich nichts
besonderes wenn man sie so sieht wird
man denken okay 60 euro vielleicht diese
hier kostet auch einfach 700 euro es
geht wohl immer hier um dieses big star
ich weiß nicht genau was das ist ich bin
kein fashion youtuber auch so das heißt
einfach hose auf schwedisch als ich habe
wirklich keine ahnung warum das total
ist schreibt gerne in die kommentare
wenn jetzt wisst aber hier sieht man das
kostet halt wirklich so viel auch hier
das t shirt was ja eben schon dran kam
auch 350 euro jetzt halt einfach so
warum auch immer da zu werfen ist viel
anstrengender als man denkt ich habe
keinen plan beim welchen betrag ich
jetzt bin er ist ja irgendwie
unglaublich eingeblendet meine neue
klamotten sind immer gut aber ich freue
mich auch nochmal sehr wenig schnäppchen
schieße und die hose gerade ist absolut
kein schnäppchen so leute als nächstes
ist mein bruder dran der möchte jetzt
auch mal fast schon mittags geworfen
früher also was auf wegen hierzu
markierung kann man wird vor dir hast du
jetzt unterwäsche das heißt du darfst
jetzt zwei pfeile werfen und die pfeile
die am nächsten dran sind die bekommst
du ja und schränke ich anwalt wenn du
glück hast gebe ich dir was davon auch
die sachen ja was ja wir haben auch noch
gleich kommen auch sonnenbrillen h
das geht besser was ist das denn alter
ja hier kannst du mal werfen
ja aber du musst irgendwas hiervon
treffen noch einmal kommt jetzt aber mal
ja
tja jetzt gibt sie nur auf das kann man
gar nicht erkennen was ist das denn wir
haben ja wenn's strümpfe für 16 euro
zweimal hätte jetzt weil man ja stimme
ist okay strom vorhanden war
du darfst du auch mal werfen und zwar
geht es jetzt um sonnenbrillen ich habe
nämlich keine einzige sonnenbrille
ich sag mal so du hast jetzt zwei pfeile
wenn du beide teile triffst dann darf
sie eine davon aus wenn man erst mal
alle dran und zwar haben wir jetzt
folgendes einmal diese sonnenbrille von
junk hat für 10 euro
diese für sieben euro diese von bands
für 18 euro und diese ray band 4 162
euro macht das mal ein bisschen schwerer
und hängen wie hier hin da ich mir das
einer von den aus als wenn wir jetzt
zwei trupps darfst dir einen aussuchen
ok meinetwegen
[Musik]
ja ja ja ja ja welche hätten gerne hier
diese für sieben euro oder diese 14 euro
also leute wir sind jetzt hier im
endeffekt noch einmal günstig davon
gekommen was unterwäsche und
sonnenbrillen angeht
ach nee warte mal das ding ist jetzt nur
ich hab eigentlich von anfang an gesagt
je näher die an dieser pin nah dran ist
oder es kommt an die nadeldrucker an
weil selbst wenn die jetzt hier gelandet
ist zählt eigentlich diese nadel war im
letzten video aufruf als er davon nicht
gesehen hat das heißt eigentlich hätten
wir hier jetzt diese und diese
ergebnisse aus
an einer stelle würde ich auf jeden fall
die gelbe nehmen weil ich bin mir sicher
die steht ihr gut
nimmst du ja leute werden jetzt einige
sachen erschossen ich habe es hier
einmal dreiviertelstunde in der sonne
pfeile geworfen
das ist auf jeden fall noch nach oben
dafür noch ein paar schreibt auch gerne
in die kommentare was man noch eher
werfen könnte oder irgendwie eine andere
43 das ist eine landkarte die brauche
ich nur so weit ich bin jetzt gerade
noch im schnitt eigentlich sollte das
video schon gestern anleihen kommen
kommt allerdings erst heute online heute
regt jetzt einfach draußen ich habe die
ganzen sachen jetzt erworben und die
werde ich jetzt bestellen und dann gibt
es da bald ein video zu wie ich die
auspacken
darunter natürlich auch die schule für
meine mutter die wird sich sicherlich
sehr freuen
ansonsten hoffe ich natürlich oder was
ich gern noch sagen wollte es ist nicht
wichtig mögliche klamotten zu tragen ich
feiere meistens auch t shirts für 15
euro oder so viel mehr als irgendwie so
teure sachen heute dazu verleihen china
ich würde sagen wir haben wirklich
einige coole sachen dabei und ich bin
gespannt wenn sie da sind check ins netz
ab genießt das schöne wetter wir sind
uns sonntag oder montag wieder